[Music]
hello i'm willy king
king of broadway action the story of
little voice is about a young woman
named best king
and she's stepping into young adulthood
her
brother has moved into a group home
louie is that's his
older brother everything you need to
know about broadway he's all into
showbiz
kevin is uniquely able he went on a
nationwide search for kevin
there is something unforgettable
something so precious about him
he's just a really special actor i
believe that my career as an autistic
person can show what everybody can do
working in theater requires a certain
theatrical flair oh my god it's nicholas
christopher
will you sign my playbill kevin embraced
learning about
theater in new york it was great to
watch him dig into all of that
to find someone who could not just fit
the characters written but elevate it
and we finally found kevin these were
our favorite days on set we're being any
of the scenes where we were working with
louie or his buddies had an incredible
experience with kevin
kevin is an incredibly committed actor
this is big news
every scene we ever did just so much fun
hear your tickets enjoy the show
one unexpected moment can change your
whole future
you